ah
shall come back to new rock stars I'm
Anna Vance and today we're going to be
looking at the Fantastic animated movie
The Little Mermaid and if you wanted 10
fun facts about this Exquisite movie
grab your seats because you might just
get your fish wish sorry this show is
far too sophisticated for puns as you
may know there are hundreds of facts
about The Little Mermaid but here are 10
particularly fun ones two of the most
iconic things about The Little Mermaid
are Ariel's red hair and the song Part
of Your World but both of these things
are actually on the chopping block at
one point in Treasures Untold the making
of The Little Mermaid associate producer
Maureen Donley said that everyone would
walk into the room with a different
vision of Ariel in their heads an early
concept art reflects this writer
director and producer John musker and
co-writer and co-director Ron Clements
claimed that they always had envisioned
Ariel as a redhead but the German at the
time Jeffrey katzenberg was shocked the
first time he saw Ariel animated as a
redhead he apparently argued that
everybody knows that all mermaids are
blonde
[Applause]
several cases were made for her having
red hair Disney had already had two
blonde princesses and one princess with
black hair and the movie Splash had
recently come out which featured a
blonde mermaid
and considering that the close proximity
of that movie's release almost prevented
the idea of another mermaid film
entirely they wanted to set Ariel apart
from splash's main character as much as
possible the case was also made that the
red provided a nice contrast from the
Green in her tail and the mainly blue
background and that it was easier to
make red hair darker when Ariel was in
Shadow than it was to make blonde hair
darker so the red ended up winning out
Jeffrey wasn't the one rooting for a
blonde aerial though Tycho the toy
company who first produced The Little
Mermaid toys were alarmed by her having
red hair stating that red-headed dolls
didn't sell as well as their blonde and
brunette dolls and when the dolls of
Ariel first came out companies were so
hesitant to give her bright red hair
that for a while Ariel dolls had
strawberry blonde hair even at Disney
Parks they didn't fully commit to the
red but it turned out kids loved the red
hair and they were so disappointed by
the strawberry blonde that the companies
redesigned everything and went with the
Striking hair color we all know and love
but what about Part of Your World How
could a song that Paramount to the movie
be up for consideration to be cut it all
starts with popcorn kinda once we had a
rough animated storyboard of the movie
they wanted a test audience to page
reactions so they invited children from
a local school to watch the movie at
their Studio hearing Part of Your World
which was about halfway animated and
still in black and white the kids
started fidgeting a little and
everything went South when one kid
dropped their popcorn if you've ever
worked with or even been around on a
group of children you'll know how easily
they get distracted so that sort of
restlessness rippled throughout the
group leaving them inattentive during
the song katzenberg took this as a sign
that the song wasn't going to work as it
couldn't hold kids attention and said it
should be cut all right Jeff shift we
gotta talk Howard's in horror were and
horror the rest
animator Glenn Keane told him to at
least let him finish animating it that
katzenberg agreed to give it one more
chance thankfully everyone at the second
showing of a fully animated one were
still and transfixed during the song
letting it remain in the film Ariel
wasn't just reaching for the surface she
was reaching for Jeff's heart speaking a
part of your world there are a few real
world references in her Grotto that we
can see throughout the song she seems so
proud of bust of Abraham Lincoln in her
Ventures and the painting we see when
she's singing what's the word burn I
can't help myself I'm so sorry is the
painting mandolin with a smoking Flame
by Josh
but those aren't the only things snuck
into the background there are quite a
few cameos from some recognizable
characters in this movie as well the
king and Duke from Cinderella are in
attendance at Vanessa and Eric's wedding
that gets interrupted the fish form of
Mr Limpet from the incredible Mr Olympic
can be seen at the end of under the sea
there's a possible auroran Philip cameo
in the painting at the castle and Kermit
as well as Goofy Donald and Mickey are
in attendance at King Triton's concert
while we're talking about that concert
one of my favorite fun facts is that
while King Triton makes his grand
entrance to a full Orchestra
Sebastian enters to a lone kazoo which
composer Alan Menken revealed in the
movie's commentary track that he played
himself
imagining him playing that last note
never fails to make me laugh some other
Creator nods also snuck into the movie
via Ariel's sisters now there's a whole
song dedicated to Ariel's sister's name
so you got Dasher and Dancer and no okay
sorry wrong song No Ariel's sisters
names all start and end with a aquata
andrina Arista Tina Adela and Alana and
in the movie's commentary track they
talk about some of the cute backstories
Behind these names Athena is referencing
a rock Musical that menkin made called
Athena evil queen of the Galaxy Ashman
named one of the sisters Alana as a nod
to Allen and Serena was actually the
name of Ron Clements as aerobics teacher
at the time we made this video with the
help of geology and with their help you
can make your skin healthier than ever
geology is a 22 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ their products are
built around just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have entrusted
by dermatite colleges for decades just
take a quick 30 second diagnostic quiz
in geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you geology's
co-wash and deodorant are great and I
use them all the time but right now
they're running a special offer for a
skin care sampler pack and glg's Skin
Care stuff is in a league of its own
geology's line of skin care products can
help you fight acne reduce oiliness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging there has
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a very limited time
use code rockstars 100 to get 100 off
your personalized 30-day skincare sample
set all you have to do is cover the 495
for shipping on top of that new
rockstars fans get an exclusive bonus
offer up to 50 off on an additional skin
hair or body product of your choice when
you add it to your trial click the link
in the description or go to
geolog.i.e rockstars100 to get started
moving on to another character we only
get a limited time with Americans know
Chef Louie as being an over-the-top
French stereotype but how does that play
in the French dub I was amazed to find
out that in the original 1990 French dub
of the movie Chef Louie is Italian
not only that but it's apparently pretty
common for French doves to turn our
stereotypically French characters into
Italian ones like Lumiere from Beauty
and the Beast and Pepe Le Pew from
Looney Tunes are also Italian in the
French dubs this is mostly done by
Rolling the R's but the gestures and
character design that we consider
stereotypically French they know as
stereotypically Italian which I think is
hilarious there was also a great comment
left at a quora forum about this by
someone who grew up watching the French
dub and was pickled pink to find out
that he was originally supposed to be
French saying that they always wondered
why the French can can was playing in
the background when the Italian chef
chases Sebastian but that it made a lot
more sense now while this movie had an
incredible cast of colorful characters
and unique personalities originally
there were two more featured characters
that ended up being cut the first was a
character called Harold the merman who
was going to serve as an example of how
Ursula tricks people with her deals
Ursula would have made a deal with
Harold that she would give him muscles
in exchange for him getting her water
lily within three days only knowing they
were out of season she would then
assumingly turn him into one of those
weird little sea slug dudes instead they
presumably replaced this with showing
the results of people not fulfilling
their side of the bargain during Poor
Unfortunate Souls the other character
that was cut was a dolphin named breaker
that was going to be another one of
Ariel's animal friends Ricker was going
to be energetic and gun hoe and when it
was decided that breaker would get cut
due to Ariel having too many Animal
Companions they opted to integrate those
personality traits into Ariel enhancing
her excitable nature and passion for
exploring there are quite a few Dolphins
throughout the movie and who knows if
one of them might just be named breaker
the cast of The Little Mermaid did an
incredible job bringing the characters
to life and it's hard to imagine anyone
else voicing them but there were
actually quite a few famous faces that
were considered for roles during casting
and here's the thing there's a lot of
names floating around out there on the
internet of who was up for what but if I
couldn't trace it back to a source who
worked on the movie I ain't talking
about it but we learned from an
interview with musker and Clemens that
they auditioned comedians Bill Maher and
Michael Richards for the voice of
scuttle before landing on comedian Buddy
Hackett and the Jim Carrey was up for
the role of Prince Eric and wore a
baseball hat into the audition to come
off as more youthful but everyone knows
the propeller beanie is the way to go if
you want to look young and Prince Eric
actually had one in the first draft okay
the last part's not true Unfortunately
they also talk about the process of
creating and casting Ursula and we get
even more insight into how Ursula was
cast in their interview for the book
making Tunes inside the most popular
animated TV shows and movies by Alan
newer in it they talk about how prior to
writing the script writer Howard Ashman
was a big fan of the TV show Dynasty and
pictured Ursula as a Joan Collins type
and even wanted her to voice it the
musker and Clements picture B Arthur
voicing the role and even wrote her name
into the script when describing Ursula
describing the witch as having a bee
Arthur type bass of voice problem was
when Arthur's agent read the script she
was highly offended at the idea that
they would consider her client as a
witch type and turned it down after that
several more actresses auditioned
including Nancy marchland Nancy Wilson
Gretchen Weiler Charlotte Ray Elaine
Stritch and Roseanne yes Roseanne
apparently she was brought in to read
for the head chambermaid originally and
it was then that Ashman suggested she
read for Ursula unfortunately there's no
footage of this but musker does a pretty
great Recreation of the moment in an
interview yeah Fox and jets in Your
Divine little vipers come in anyway
Charlotte Ray and Elaine Stritch were
the two that made it to the second
auditions where they would sing Poor
Unfortunate Souls but Pat Carroll was
among those who auditioned and it was a
match made in heaven and Carol not only
responded well to ashman's
interpretation of Ursula but credits his
performance as shaping Ursula as a whole
as far as her design went they tried out
various types of fish from scorpion fish
to manta rays to lionfish before
settling on an octopus which they felt
gave her the slimy slivering sort of
movement that matched the instrumentals
that played during her scenes they knew
from the beginning she would have very
theatrical sort of look and the end
result pulled most of its inspiration
from legendary drag queen Divine who
Ashman greatly admired another
interesting tidbit about Ursula is that
when she's making the potion to
transform into Vanessa a butterfly is
one of the ingredients she uses
butterflies often symbolize
transformation and it might not be a
coincidence that the butterfly she uses
has a similar orange color to the
Vanessa butterfly genus if that's on
purpose the level of detail is
incredible a similar appreciation for
detail came in when creating the bubbles
you see in the movie get ready when I
tell you that the millions of bubbles in
the movie were all hand drawn the book
the political economy of Disney the
cultural capitalism of Hollywood by
Alexander bojas talks about how the
directors wanted every bubble to be
unique and that everyone should be hand
drawn and not xeroxed back in that time
Disney used a process called cell
animation cell being short for Celluloid
artists transfer the established Line
work onto transparent sheets of thin
plastic known as cells Black Ink was
used to do the line work on one side and
then the other side would have color
applied the foreground cells would be
laid over separately created backgrounds
and boom you gotta frame and if you're
thinking that hand-drawing millions of
bubbles for that many frames would take
a lot of time and effort you'd be right
it was so consuming in fact that they
had to Outsource the task to Pacific Rim
Productions a production facility in
Beijing her Little Mermaid was the last
Disney film to ever use the traditional
hand-painted cell animation system
before they switched to a digital method
known as caps short for computer
animation production system in this
process each drawing from the animation
could be scanned onto a computer where
they could be colored with far more
control and options in regards to color
palette shading blending and more and
then easily composited over scanned
background paintings some went
beautifully while The Little Mermaid was
the end of an air in Disney Animation it
was also the beginning of one as the
very first time Disney ever used Cavs
technology was to make the rainbow in
the last shot of the movie animation
cells got me teared up well those were
our 10 fun facts about the 1989 Little
Mermaid now I could have said acrylian
more what are some of your other
favorite factoids about the movie as
always check your sources and let me
know what other Disney Pixar or Disney
Pixar movies you want to hear 10 fun
facts about in the comments until then
you can follow me on Twitter at it's
anavanston and follow And subscribe to
new rockstars and new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love ah it
doesn't get better than this
[Music]
thank you